what do you think about
uh dojo with tesla and
their foray into what appears to be
specialized hardware for our training no
nets
i guess it's something maybe you can
correct me for my
shallow looking at it it seems like
something like google did with tpus but
specialized
for uh driving data i don't think it's
specialized for driving data
it's just legit just tpu they want to
inter go the apple way basically
everything required in the chain is done
in-house well so you have a problem
right now and this
is one of my one of my concerns
i really would like to see somebody deal
with this if anyone out there is doing
it i'd
like to help them if i can um you
basically have two options right now
to train uh your options are nvidia or
google
um so google is not even an option
uh their tpus are only available in
google cloud
uh google has absolutely onerous terms
of service restrictions
uh they may have changed it but back in
google's terms of service it said
explicitly you are not allowed to use
google cloud ml
for training autonomous vehicles or for
doing anything that competes with google
without google's prior written
permission
well okay i mean google is not a
platform company
i wouldn't i wouldn't touch tpus with a
10 foot pole so
that leaves you with the monopoly uh
nvidia and video
so i mean that you're not a fan of well
look i was a huge fan of in 2016 nvidia
jensen came sat in the car um
cool guy when the stock was thirty
dollars a share
uh nvidia stock has skyrocketed um i
witnessed a real
change in who was in management over
there in like 2018
and now they are let's exploit let's
take every dollar we possibly can out of
this ecosystem
let's charge ten thousand dollars for
a100s because we know we got the best
in the game
and let's charge ten thousand dollars
for an a100
when it's really not that different from
3080 which is 699.
um the margins that they are making off
of those high-end chips are
so high that i mean i think they're
shooting themselves
in the foot just from a business
perspective because there's a lot of
people talking like me now
who are like somebody's got to take a
video down
yeah where they could dominate it nvidia
could be the new intel
yeah to be in inside everything
essentially
and and yet the winners in in certain
spaces like
autonomous driving the winners only the
people who are like
desperately falling back and trying to
catch up and have a ton of money like
the big automakers
are the ones interested in partnering
with nvidia oh and i think a lot of
those things are going to fall through
if i were nvidia sell chips
sell chips at a reasonable markup to
everybody to everybody
without any restrictions without any
restrictions intel did this
look at intel they had a great long run
nvidia is trying to turn their they're
like trying to productize their chips
way too much they're trying to extract
way more value than they can
sustainably sure you can do it tomorrow
is it gonna up your share price
sure if you're one of those ceos like
how much can i strip mine this company
and
you know and that's what's weird about
it too like the ceo is the founder
it's the same guy yeah i mean i still
think jensen's a great guy
is great why do this you have a choice
you have a choice right now are you
trying to cash out you trying to buy a
yacht
if you are fine but if you're trying to
be
the next huge semiconductor company sell
chips well the
the interesting thing about jensen is he
is
a big vision guy so he has
a plan like for 50 years down the road
so it makes me wonder like how does
price gouging fit into it
yeah how does that like it's it doesn't
seem to
make sense to plan i worry that he's
listening to the wrong people
yeah that that's the sense i have too
sometimes because
i despite everything i think nvidia
is an incredible company well one sort
of i'm deeply grateful to nvidia for the
products they've created me to pass
right
and so the 1080 ti was a great gpu still
have a lot of them
it was yeah but
at the same time it just feels like
it feels like you don't want to put all
your stock in nvidia and so i think elon
is doing um
what tesla is doing with autopilot and
dojo is
the apple way is because they're not
going to share dojo with uh
george haws i i i know they should sell
that chip
oh they should sell their even their
their accelerator the accelerator that's
in all the cars the 30 watt one
sell it why not so open it up
make me why does this have to be a car
company
well if you sell the chip here's what
you get yeah
make some money off the chips it doesn't
take away from your chip
you're gonna make some money free money
and also
the world is gonna build an ecosystem of
tooling for you
right you're not gonna have to fix the
bug in your tan h layer
someone else already did well the
question that's an interesting question
i mean that's the question steve jobs
asked that's the question elon musk is
perhaps asking is uh
do you want tesla stuff inside other
vehicles in
inside potentially inside like uh irobot
vacuum cleaner
yeah i think you should decide where
your advantages are
i'm not saying tesla should start
selling battery packs to automakers
because battery packs to automakers they
are straight up in competition with you
if i were tesla i'd keep the battery
technology totally yeah ssr's we make
batteries
but the thing about the tesla tpu um
is anybody can build that it's just a
question of you know
are you willing to spend the you know
the money it could be a huge source of
revenue potentially
are you willing to spend a hundred
million dollars right anyone can build
it
and someone will and a bunch of
companies now are starting trying to
build ai accelerators somebody's going
to get the idea right
and yeah hopefully they don't get greedy
because they'll just lose to the next
guy who finally and then eventually the
chinese are going to make knockoff and
video chips and that's
you